China admits it detained a top
international police official after he
mysteriously vanished during a trip home
mung Heung whay resigned as a head of
Interpol that's the global police agency
Beijing says he's being held for its
suspected bribery his detention is now
shining a harsh light on China's
sweeping an authoritarian crackdown on
alleged graft and disloyalty Ben Tracy
is following this story from Beijing Ben
what can you tell us good morning good
morning this was a bold and brazen move
by the Chinese government and it could
have significant consequences some are
now questioning whether or not Chinese
officials should be allowed to leave
international organizations if the
Chinese government can simply make them
vanish now Mong Heung whay was named
president of Interpol in 2016 and was
living in France he came back to China
for a visit last month and that is when
he went missing his wife says before he
disappeared she received this text
message from him showing a knife to warn
her that he was in danger the Chinese
government now admits they detained
Hmong and are accusing him of taking
bribes and other crimes
now Interpol says it was not informed
that Hmong was under investigation
the Chinese only admitted to having him
in custody after Interpol demanded an
explanation Chinese President Xi
Jingping has led a high-profile
crackdown on corruption in the Communist
Party in the past six years 1.5 million
party officials have been punished but
this is also widely viewed as a way for
Xi to take down political rivals and
those he finds disloyal now here in
China the courts answer to the Communist
Party so mungs detention is basically
the same thing as a conviction and he
could even face the death penalty
bianna such an incredible mystery Ben
Tracy and Beijing thank you